now there's the idea there's the idea
okay
but we've been doing trig functions trig
functions
let's have a look at these symmetries i
need to draw this again but you can just
refer back to the beautiful graphs we
drew
last friday okay i'm going to start with
cos
cos is the easiest
that's what cos looks like from minus
360
to positive 360. you tell me what kind
of symmetry is that
quite clearly i can reflect across the
y-axis so
cos cos x you shouldn't even write this
cos x is an even function
okay that means that just like over here
i made this statement about
f this function right well i can make
every statement about an even function i
can make about cos
because cos is even so for instance i
can say cos
of x is equal to
cos of minus x for any value right so if
i ask you what's cos of 30
right it's going to be the same as cos
of minus 30.
okay so if i ask you to work out this
you can just go straight there
or vice versa if you so true okay
cos is an even function and we can take
advantage of this in other ways but
before we do that let's have a look at
the other two and you'll see why i group
them
think about sine
sorry here's sign right i've done it
again from -360 all the way over to 360.
it's a bit rough but you get the idea
what kind of symmetry is there
well it is so reflective but it's at a
different point
ah now you got to be careful right
because to to
reflect say this part to get to this
part
you've got to reflect twice no matter
which way you go about it for instance
if i reflect across this way i'm going
to have to reflect again this way
reflect twice in order to get there in
one movement
i'm going to have to do the same thing i
did over here with x cubed i'm going to
have to take
this and rotate it around okay can you
see let me just draw in an extra um
construction for you so you can see it
if i rotate it at 90 degrees
it would look like this right can you
see that
rotate it and then when i run it again
this peak here has become going to
become this trough
over here right so it goes around
like that so i have rotational symmetry
here
so sine sine is an odd function
sine x is an odd function if you draw
the lines like
um 90 degrees to the left
yes that's true but then i've shifted it
as well as reflecting it
so then it's it's not reflected anymore
all right so therefore everything i say
about odd functions i can say about sine
i can say sine of minus x is equal to
minus sine of x you can go ahead and
verify this right
we've looked at this questions like this
sine of minus 30
it's equal to minus sine theta it's fine
right look because sine 30 is a half so
minus sine 30
is minus a half which sure enough is um
sine of minus theta okay so you go round
and round you can see what's going on
okay so to take advantage of this oh by
the way
what's tan you don't even need to draw
it do you
it's clearly it's rotational you can see
the arms rotating around
just out of curiosity
odd function divided by an even function
gives you an odd function
what about just this is a rhetorical
question i want you to think about it
what about if we reversed it do you get
the same do you get different why or why
not you ever think about it
okay now i'm going to pick out a
question that got asked me so
i can show you how to take advantage of
this right so the question i got asked
was i think it was cot of
660 okay so i'm going to take advantage
of two things number one
this whole symmetry business okay and
i'm also going to take advantage of the
fact that
all of these functions are periodic they
repeat
okay so remember how we established
before
if i have sine of some angle like say
30. sorry i
sound like a broken record but i keep
going back to because it's an easy
number
if i add 360 degrees to that
i'll be the same agreed yep so you've
got
10 percent it'll survive
now that's a sign cos is the same cos 30
would be cos
390 okay tan is different
10 is different if i get 10 or 30 i can
go
360 but the period of 10 is different
right what's the period
180. so in fact i could go 360 but i
only have to go
180 degrees and that will be the same
you agree with that
now cot
which function is it which function is a
reciprocal of
it's reciprocal of tan okay so therefore
i can go
backwards or forward any multiple
of 180 like i did here and i'll be the
same
does that make sense so i'm going to go
all the way back to
i'm going to go 720 degrees backwards
are you okay with that
720 degrees i just pick 720 because it
gives me an acute angle
that's a cube okay so cot i'm going to
get rid of that so that's one on tan
now we just talked about the fact that
tan is an odd function
so instead of saying tan of negative 60
i should be able to say the same thing
about it that i said about all the odd
functions namely it's 1
on minus tan 60 and now i have an exact
value
if i recall 1060 is root three root
three
yeah so i'll pop the minus sign at the
top minus one on
root three okay
so what have i done i've taken advantage
of the symmetry
to change the science i've taken
advantage of the periodicity
to go back and forth to an angle that's
convenient to me not some
ridiculous unmanageable angle and that
combination of things
will serve most of your answers okay
most of the questions you get